the pandemic has changed almost every
facet of life including
air travel one airline is giving cbs
news an exclusive preview of what could
be
the future of flying united is the first
u.s airline to offer passengers access
to
in airport corona virus testing through
its app and website transportation
correspondent errol barnett joins us
from newark liberty international
airport errol good morning
good morning anthony and welcome to what
travel experts suggest
very well could be the new normal this
testing location
opening just minutes ago united airlines
is the first to offer a place not just
to book your ticket
but also schedule a cover test and
upload the results
all in one app the hope is to help you
be travel ready
in a world where there's anything but
uniformity
almost a year into the pandemic there's
still widespread confusion over how to
follow a patchwork of covet guidelines
and protocols around the us
and the world i was thinking the whole
the time as
i was coming here waiting for my cobra
test to come in it adds
another layer onto your travel that in
normal circumstances you don't have to
worry about
united airlines aims to fix that with
its brand new
digital travel ready center where you
can do everything from check
covert requirements to schedule a test
at the terminal
so instead of jumping around from page
to page on government websites
state local websites relevant
information
is attached directly to your ticket
based on where you're going that's
exactly right
based on the ticket that you purchased
um tailored to you
so that you will know everything that
you need particularly as
all the coved kind of landscape is
changing it works like this
now once your ticket is booked you can
locate it inside the united app
or on its website and scroll down to the
travel ready center
here you'll see testing requirements
based on your destination
now you can schedule that test through
this service
and one of the new locations is here
inside united's terminal c
i am here for a covert test okay you
have an appointment
yes you can follow me sir on friday
express check
demonstrated its testing process to cbs
news before its new pop-up site opens at
newark liberty international airport
today
ceo doug satzman says his company
express spa
group is uniquely positioned to offer
cover testing
inside the terminal well our spa
business closed down
at the end of march so we have three
zones we have check-in
we have testing rooms and then we have a
full-service lab
once tested passengers upload results to
their booking profile
the airlines are investing in providing
testing because they know
it's good business travel analyst henry
hardeveldt says this
move stems from necessity some countries
or destinations want you to have a pcr
test others will take an antigen
test so it's really confusing dr
william schaffner notes this process is
certainly more straightforward
and suggests it very well could be the
future of flying
but he also says that while my rapid
test was negative
it still does not guarantee 100 percent
safety it's not perfect
but it is another layer that could be
introduced
to help reduce the risk like 911 changed
airport security forever we're still
taking our shoes off covid
is going to change safety protocol in
airports for a long time as well
now united says since this app launched
just a few weeks ago it's seen hundreds
of thousands of customers
upload their covet results directly to
the app and we should also note
they do also provide the pcr or antigen
test
in addition to the rapid s you saw me
receive
and right now the places to get this
done here in newark at san francisco
and lax airport scale with the plan
to expand this nationwide now go you all
taking the test on camera because i'm a
big baby when my turn comes with
anything to do with the layers to make
it safer for us
is always a good thing thank you very
much